[Music]
few actors get pitch and hold more than
those who specialize in sci-fi which is
part of the reason why you don't really
hear from the following sci-fi stars
anymore some of them took on new jobs in
the film industry while others left it
entirely
roxanne dawson rose to fame as half
human half klingon bolana torres
on star trek voyager over the course of
seven seasons she got promoted
fell in love and had a child behind the
scenes dawson wanted a chance to do what
so many other track actors did direct an
episode
she got her chance with season six's
riddles as well as season 7's workforce
part 2.
she then directed 10 episodes of star
trek enterprise and has spent the
following years as one of the most
in-demand tv directors around
she's helmed episodes of everything from
other genre material like agents of
shield to more sober political fair like
house of cards in 2019 she made her big
screen directing debut with the
christian drama breakthrough
dawson stopped acting regularly in 2003
with her last credit coming as a guest
on a 2011 episode of the closer
it's not impossible that she'll return
in front of the camera one day but don't
count on it as she told star trek.com in
2011
i would be sad to think that i'll never
act again but there's not really an
opportunity now
i can't pursue it and i don't have the
time at the moment i don't miss it but i
always think that i'll do it again at
some point when it becomes convenient
but it hasn't been yet keith hamilton
cobb is probably best known as tough as
nails mercenary tear on the space opera
series andromeda
despite how natural he was at playing an
intergalactic leg breaker the role was
something of an outlier for cobb as he
was a trained theater actor who made his
name in soap operas
he returned to the soap world after
andromeda ended but he hasn't appeared
in any kind of screen role since 2007.
he hasn't abandoned acting completely
though instead he's just moved entirely
to the stage alongside several other
creative endeavors like furniture making
and writing
in particular cobb has spent the last
several years working on and touring
with his show americanmoore
based on an uncomfortable audition for
shakespeare play the show presents
cobb's dissection of the issue of race
and theater
americanmoore features him as an actor
auditioning for the title role in
othello all while the unseen director
pushes back against the performance
the first reading took place in 2013 and
he since toured the country with it
including an off-broadway run in 2019.
the show's message
resonates in unexpected ways a 16 year
old jewish girl
she gets up and says that's my story
robert duncan mcneil started his career
with small sci-fi guest spots in the 80s
before landing his first big role in
1992
cadet nicholas locarno on the star trek
the next generation episode the first
duty
three years later he landed the gig that
defined him tom paris on star trek
voyager
after that show wrapped up after seven
seasons in 2001 mcneil made a few tv
guest appearances before phasing out of
acting entirely
he hasn't disappeared though like his
voyager co-star roxanne dawson he's just
moved behind the camera
mcneil had wanted to direct before
voyager but his shows kept getting
cancelled before he had the opportunity
as he revealed to star trek.com on the
first day of the voyager pilot he
approached producer rick berman to make
it clear that he wanted to direct an
episode as soon as possible he then
started shadowing other trek directors
while spending time in edit bays and
screenings with berman
the first episode mcneal directed was
season 3's sacred ground
he went on to direct three more episodes
of voyager as well as four episodes of
star trek enterprise
he's since gone on to direct a variety
of other shows including everything from
desperate housewives to supernatural
carrie hand played little newt the
soot-faced beating heart of 1986's
aliens
despite delivering an excellent
performance at a young age she never
acted in another movie ever again
instead opting for another profession
entirely hen was cast at the age of nine
while living in the uk and she got the
role despite having no previous acting
experience of any kind
to this day she reportedly remains in
contact with her co-star sigourney
weaver soon after aliens came out the
hen family moved to america
attempts to include newton alien 3 fell
apart but weaver invited her to the
premiere nonetheless
by that point ten wasn't involved in
acting anyway instead she was a normal
high school student
the main reason that she didn't return
to acting was that she simply had no
desire to as she instead went on to
focus on teaching
as recently as 2016 she was an
elementary school teacher in northern
california
albeit one who occasionally signs aliens
dvds for students
when asked by blackgate.com in 2018 if
she'd ever returned to acting she said
as a busy wife mom and teacher i'm not
sure i would have the time to devote to
reprising my role
however i would love to do a cameo in an
alien franchise film with the
opportunity
arose we better get back because it'll
be dark soon
and they mostly come at night mostly
janette goldstein is best known for
playing space marine vasquez an
alien which was just the start for the
character actress she'd go on to appear
in some more sci-fi properties
afterwards including max headroom and
star trek generations
she also played john connor's foster mom
in terminator 2 judgement day her screen
credits started slowing down in the
mid-2000s with her last major
live-action role being a 2010 guest spot
on medium
this slowdown is in large part due to
her focusing on a new business venture
in 2009 goldstein and her husband
launched jeanette braws
stemming from her frustration in finding
bras that could accommodate both her
large bust and small ribcage the store
lives by the motto
the alphabet starts at d i remember
thinking i look
matronly and um
and like a stripper at the same time
goldstein started by importing high-end
bras from europe and her business grew
so much that she now has five stores in
two states
in 2016 she told cnbc that she was on
pace for 1.7 million dollars in sales
that year and that she was now more
recognized around los angeles as the
brawl lady rather than an actress
terry farrell played jadzia dax on star
trek deep space nine
for six seasons before getting killed
off reportedly after producer rick
berman refused to let her have a lighter
workload she then moved on to the cbs
sitcom becker and appeared in a few
movies but then stopped acting on screen
altogether after 2003 as she chose to
focus on her family
soon after her time on becker she moved
to hershey pennsylvania to raise her son
with her then husband brian baker
best known as the trench coat wearing
salesman in early 2000s sprint
commercials
she wanted stability for her son after
watching her own mother go through a few
divorces and she also wanted to commit
to raising him full time
outside of family time farrell found
other pursuits to keep herself grounded
she became a yoga instructor logging the
requisite 200 hours and teaching in
class at her local rec center in 2009
she and baker starred in a play together
at a local playhouse which
was the sum total of her acting for
years what's good about the intimacy
here is it's not really that different
when
a crew is all around you and you're
working in 2011 farrell told star
trek.com that she had retired from
acting but in 2017 she came out of
retirement to appear in the fan film
star trek renegades
anthony simcoe was a human behind dargo
fanscape's luxon warrior
playing the role from 1999 to 2004 the
six-foot five-inch australian combined
his intimidating figure with a natural
charm to become one of the most
memorable characters on the series
the heavy prosthetics that he wore meant
that he could have had a long career
post-farscape without getting typecast
but instead he spent a few years taking
on smaller roles before leaving acting
altogether
simcoe's twitter page describes him as a
former actor after he retired he started
simcoe consulting a global firm that
teaches business communication
companies across the world hire him to
help them with professional training as
he employs skills he learned during his
time acting
during a 2018 appearance on the punching
sideways podcast he noted
i've got a real passion for helping
people get along i'm one of those lucky
people who found their thing
in addition to consulting simcoe is also
a doctoral student studying storytelling
and machine learning
sabrina lloyd gained sci-fi fame in the
90s as wade one of the original lead
characters on the show sliders
the same decade she also had a lead role
in the decidedly not sci-fi show sports
night
her acting workload slowed down in the
new millennium with her only notable
role coming in the cbs series numbers
before fizzling out entirely
lloyd had settled in new york during her
acting career with her future husband
who was working at the united nations at
the time
one day he proposed marriage and
suggested that they moved to africa to
which she enthusiastically agreed
as lloyd revealed on the design mom blog
when people ask how she could give up
such a successful career her response is
how could i not i knew the acting world
so well i knew the streets of my city so
well
and here was the love of my life
stretching out his hands saying let's go
see the world
the couple ended up moving around the
world together including stops in uganda
where lloyd adopted one child and rome
where she gave birth to another
they're now primarily based in kenya
while also spending part of their time
in vancouver
jake lloyd was a rising child star when
he played anakin skywalker in star wars
episode 1 the phantom menace in 1999.
it's hard to imagine a role with higher
expectations in movie history
alas the negative response to his
performance fed into issues that led to
his retirement from acting
he quit around 2001 though he continued
to make the odd convention appearance
in 2012 he made it clear in an interview
with the sun that his disillusionment
with acting could be traced directly to
star wars as he put it
my entire school life was really a
living hell and i had to do up to 60
interviews a day
lloyd also blamed george lucas in
particular and destroyed every piece of
star wars memorabilia he owned
then in 2015 after lloyd physically
assaulted his mother she confirmed to
tmz that he was diagnosed with
schizophrenia when he was 19.
later that year he was arrested for
reckless driving driving without a
license and resisting
arrest he was moved to a psychiatric
facility while awaiting trial and his
family issued a statement in january
2020 saying that he had made progress
with his mental health struggles
randy ledvert started her career as a
penthouse pet but then she headed to
acting school
her first movie role was a small part in
1993's demolition man
and then several years later she had a
major part in season two of sci-fi as
the invisible man
but the most notable role of her career
was the android doyle in season 5 of
andromeda which lasted from 2004 to 2005
but her acting work dried up soon after
that due partly to motherhood but far
more to addiction
ledford started smoking marijuana at age
11 and by 14 she was regularly doing
coke and drinking alcohol
she spent almost all of her modeling
days doing uppers and downers to keep
herself going
she would stay clean while shooting but
party too much after work
having a child kept her clean for a few
years but her old habits eventually
destroyed her marriage and her
relationship with her son
she also stopped acting altogether after
a mental health incident forced her into
rehab she started getting her life back
together
she also had what she's called a miracle
baby at the age of 44.
ledford has been sober since 2012 and
regularly shares her story of addiction
to help others
she has unofficially retired and with a
story like hers a comeback can't be
ruled out
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
be sure to reach out to the substance
abuse and mental health services
administration
samsa at 1-800-662-help
4357